yeah I'm curious who do you think in
your opinion is the greatest Tech
entrepreneur of all time oh
Tech entrepreneur interesting Does Elon
count as an entrepreneur I think so yeah
I think he kind of swoops into companies
that are on their way and makes a huge
difference but maybe if an entrepreneur
is like someone who started a company
um
Tang entrepreneur
I don't know that any of the people I'm
thinking of are like truly starting the
companies the ones that come to mind
yeah jobs was like Arc is fundamental to
Apple's formative years and like he's a
big reason why they are what they are
then to open it up against Tech Pioneer
yeah yeah it's probably Elon Elon really
yeah it's just like the the vision he
has to have for the future I and I
specifically look at Tesla when I look
at that it's just like
the reason every single other car
company in the world which is a hundred
years old is going oh we need to change
what we're doing just because of what
that company did improved that electric
cars could be cool and useful and
actually a better car he said something
in your in your interview
he was really harping on how competitive
the car industry was yes but he said it
almost like
it was some Mafia [ __ ] like he kind of
like laughed to himself a little bit he
was like yeah it's really hard yeah like
this is really competitive do you know
what he's
really trying to say I think he's saying
every car company in the U.S other than
Ford and maybe one other one has either
died or been bailed out by the
government like it's super easy to just
run out of money yeah and so I think
he's like very proud of the fact that
Tesla didn't die or run out of money
they've been very close they have needed
government subsidies but like
it's hard to make a car company yeah and
they're what other new car companies can
you think of that suddenly have like the
mass market like Prius of California
like what are the new they're all old
companies they've been around forever so
making a new car company
and in 15 years being ubiquitous on the
streets all over the world is really
arguably impressive really hard to beat
that system like the one thing like the
mafia you have to buy a car through a
dealership and he went over that oh
that's right yeah I think a lot of that
is like the way of thinking I think it
would probably bite him a lot too which
is like the way it's being done right
now that doesn't have to keep going we
don't have to do it the way it's always
been done yeah and usually usually
that's actually there's something to it
like dealership model kind of sucks and
he was right I would rather buy my car
and customize it online and just pick it
up when it's ready and he just makes
more money because he cut out this
commission we're paying this guy yeah
but why did why did the dealership model
develop dealership model isn't that
terrible but what was it what I don't
know exactly how it started but now it's
just like yeah dealers are separate
companies and car manufacturers aren't
allowed to sell to their own cars yeah
so they sell them to dealerships and
then dealerships sell the car at the
MSRP the manufacturers suggested retail
price price the sticker price but the
dealership can just haggle do whatever
they want probably like alcohol like
like a alcohol company can on a bar it
has to go through a distributor and then
yeah and maybe that was the easiest way
to grow it is if people are just if
Chevy couldn't necessarily afford to
have 10 000 dealerships Across America
maybe but if guys like yo let me have
the dealership I'll sell your cars to
get more Chevys out on the road and then
again the internet before the internet
there was middlemen everywhere yeah so
you just needed a middleman and be like
hey let me sell this car and then I'll
get a commission yeah and then you're
just slowly just getting it but making
it illegal to sell your own cars just
seems absurd there is probably some
Monopoly protection built in or
something like that I don't know
because it because of State Franchise
laws these laws protect independent car
dealers by prohibiting manufacturers
from selling cars directly to Consumers
I guess it's just for protection for
someone yeah okay so Elon is number one
um now you said something interesting
about how he swoops in at the right time
yeah I think the majority of people
myself included C Elon as like a a true
engineer like he's in there doing the
math problems with everybody uh
but it's impossible for him to do that
with four different businesses yeah so
what is what do you think the difference
between the perception from like the
Layman's and the people who actually
know what's going on yeah I I think
there's a couple different types of
company leaders and my favorite one is
the the product guy who like knows a lot
about the product cares deeply about how
good the product is and has a vision for
what that should be and then the company
serves that vision
and I think like Tim Cook might be an
example of like the ruthless supply
chain Guy where like he's the business
guy
stock price has never been higher but
now you're not necessarily as inspired
by the new products or visions from the
company yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
we're Steve Jobs Steve exactly he's not
thinking at all about the logistics he's
there's like a famous story of like you
know weeks before the iPhone was going
to launch they had like a plastic
display and they're like guys we need it
to be glass capacitive go
and they're like that's impossible we're
launching this in two weeks it's already
done with the plastic screen he's like
it has to be glass do it and it's like
that's not gonna work guys but the
product guy was like this is gonna be
better and we've got to do it right and
this is the way it should be done where
it's like I don't know necessarily what
Tim Cook would have done in that
situation but it's like Tim Cook's gonna
find a way to get all the supply chain
stuff together to make sure they can
make enough to make sure they have their
margins high enough and that's what he
will and their stock price will be
through the roof because they'll make
tons of money but the products won't be
the same so then don't you need a Tim
Cook and a Steve yeah like don't you
need almost like a creative wild man
hopefully they're side by side I mean it
tends to be a hierarchy where like you
got one guy at the top and that's the
sort of way things go but I do like
going to a company where they're like
yeah we've got you know here's this guy
he's the boss and within like a minute
or two of talking to another person I
know if he's a product guy or a or a
design guy or an advertising guy or a
supply chain guys Tesla what are some
companies where the at the head is a
product guy product guy uh there's a car
company called Lucid that I've talked to
recently that was incredible behind the
scenes and like really great technology
that they care a lot about and I had the
guy walk me through every single thing
that he opened up a battery pack in
front of me and pointed out of things
and explained thing I was like this this
guy is good cares about the product
um and there's some people
let's see if I can think so sundars and
Google
Satya is Microsoft Bezos not anymore
I feel like a lot of these guys are
really good ruthless Business Leaders
and then right underneath them is all
the product guys yeah and they have to
convince that guy about the product oh
that's it but that's kind of interesting
like
hmm I wonder what's the better way is it
the is it the Steve at the top and then
him convincing your business guys of the
ideas or is it better to have one
business guy on the top and then your
creatives doing everything they can to
convince yeah I think you can get
carried away with a Steve if he has too
many ideas that aren't actually gonna
work you need someone to check him and
you need someone who can go that not
that one this is this is the Kanye thing
like yeah yeah it's it's a pretty like
he will be incredibly successful when
he's accompanied with an Adidas or an
actual business that has distribution
that has the factories and they can say
we're not going to do that we're gonna
make this product you said yes yesterday
we all agreed you know I need to be able
to push that line a little bit but if
you just keep going over the line over
and over there's no point in the the
other party existing yeah so you need
them to be able to offer some
flexibility and figure things out yeah I
think you need both yeah you definitely
need both yeah what do you think about
stem player
uh it was I only got to use it briefly
and it was like kind of cool yeah and
the idea of being able to like mix your
own version of a song it's cool it was
like cool toy yeah I know that it was
like some genius thing that was gonna I
guess people think it's genius when it
sells a bazillion copies or whatever
right I don't I think it was just a cool
toy it felt like a toy it didn't feel
like this was gonna change the way that
we listen to music but Kanye said he
wants to create a font he said that with
Lex he's like I want to get into
products yeah if he makes a phone wait
review
with him there yes because they're trash
into his face
[Laughter]
what's up guys that clip was brought to
you by rocket money okay this is the
personal finance app that allows you to
manage subscriptions lower bills build a
custom budget and grow your savings all
in one place that's right they're
canceling unwanted subscriptions for you
safely and secure you don't even got to
call up a company they got your back
they're low in your bills they're
literally negotiating your bills for you
all you gotta do is send them a picture
of the bill Tap a button and they got
your back and monitoring your credit
card score and much more so if you're
ready to save some money go to
rocketmoney.com flagrant or click the
link in the description below to get
started for free or unlock even more
features with premium that's
rocketmoney.com flagrant to get started
for free click the link in below